welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we officially have a
plea from accused Idaho College student
killer Brian coburger today we're
updating you on what's happened since
Monday's arraignment when the judge laid
out the charges for the defendant the
court and everyone watching at home
yes do you understand Maximus yes do you
understand the charge and count to
murder
yes do you understand the maximum health
yes do you understand the charge account
three and murder in the first degree yes
do you understand the maximum penalty
yes do you understand the charge and
count four murder in the first degree
yes do you understand the maximum
penalty yes do you understand the charge
in count five emergency
do you understand the maximum penalty
yes
and Miss Taylor is Mr co-berger prepared
to lead to these charges
Mr coburger is standing side
going to enter not guilty please on each
charge you know it's one two three four
and five all right so let's dive into
some updates and what we've learned
since that hearing first up and Taylor
coburger's public defender filed a
motion to get a copy of all the
information presented to the grand jury
the grand jury met in secret and
determined the charges for co-burger's
indictment that meant that the defendant
would not need to have a preliminary
hearing in June and could enter a plea
Taylor's looking for things like a
transcript of any evidence presented as
well as testimony the motion also asks
that any costs associated with compiling
the information paid by the county since
coburger was found to be Indigent a
second update family members of One of
coburger's victims released a statement
after the arraignment University of
Idaho students Kaylee gonsalves Maddie
Mogan Zana kernodle and Ethan Chapin
were killed in November inside an
off-campus home Kaylee's family has been
the most vocal about the investigation
and the prosecution of the case in a
statement they said quote the family
would like to thank everyone for
continuing to follow this case and keep
the memories of Kaylee of Kaylee Maddie
Zana and Ethan alive they are what is
important not the defendant we're
thankful that the laeta County District
Attorney's Office finally took the case
to a grand jury and came back with an
indictment and finally we've now learned
that at least two families have filed
notice reserving their right to sue the
city of Moscow Kaylee and Maddie's
families May seek damages against the
city after their daughters were murdered
no lawsuit has been filed as of yet but
family attorneys say that this protects
the family's rights let's break it down
joining me right now my co-hosts and
legal analyst defense attorney Brian
buckmeyer and former trial Attorney
Terry Austin Terry I'll start with you
so the families
filed this notice to reserve their right
to sue but what type of lawsuit could
they actually bring and why not just
file it now well I think they're
probably waiting to see the outcome of
the criminal trial it'll kind of bolster
their case but the notice they filed is
a requirement and it's like that in most
cities before you sue a city you
generally have to file a notice that you
are going to sue the city they didn't
put any details in this notice of claim
but I'm assuming it's going to be a
wrongful death action and for that they
are claiming that the city was negligent
that they owed a duty that Duty was
breached and I'm trying to imagine what
they are going to say that perhaps they
should have provided security and safety
I think it's going to be a difficult
claim now if they Prevail they will get
economic damages so they could get
something like lost wages for their
family members that passed and they can
also get non-economic damage which would
include loss of Consortium or loss of
you know that support that they would
have gotten from their family member
Brian the grand jury materials that the
defense wants what are they and why is
it so important to them Jesse grand jury
materials or any information I was
either presented to the grand jury or
that was created
um in front of them that could be
evidence that was presented any kind of
graphs videos photographs
um it could also be the transcripts it's
secret the grand jury process because
the defense doesn't know when it happens
who is testifying and they can't be
present for any of the testimony unless
their own clients testifies and they can
only be present for their clients
testimony so the grand jury minutes that
what are being taken down as someone
testifies is being recorded taken down
and that's the most important
information at this point and maybe even
during the trial because you get to know
who the Witnesses are what they said and
you can begin your investigation and
even maybe impeach those Witnesses come
to the time of trial and the defense
wants to know so that they can prepare a
defense for the upcoming trial in the
fall
and we're finishing Today's Show in New
Mexico where the defense attorney for
Alexi trevizo is speaking publicly about
her case Theresa is the young woman
accused of killing her newborn son in
January by stuffing him in a hospital
trash can the 19 year old had gone to
the hospital with back pain and the
staff performed a routine pregnancy test
at one point Treviso asked to go to the
bathroom and when nurses finally got her
to unlock the door the room was covered
in blood a cleaning woman found the
newborn an autopsy ruled the baby's
death a homicide saying he died from a
lack of oxygen trevisa was charged with
first-degree murder and tampering with
evidence she's pleaded not guilty in
recently released body camera video you
can hear a nurse explaining what
happened to the police
who did a pregnancy test I'm not sure
positive
denying that she had sex then she said
she had to go to the bathroom she went
to the bathroom she was in there for
quite a while we could knock on the door
finally we got her to open the door and
there was blood everywhere she was
cleaning it up so we took her back to
the room and I was afraid that she knew
she was pregnant she had done something
to herself so the doctor started doing
the vaginal exam on her we had the lady
come to clean the bathroom
she put the baby in the trash can and
then she put another clean liner over
the top of it
okay so they look when they looked in
there it looked there was no trash in
there but it's underneath the clean bag
the baby's dead
we haven't been Toronto but
she killed the kid we discovered a dead
baby in the bathroom
oh my gosh
Lexi I told you about this
I just asked you baby to tell me the
trickles
it was not
here
what did you do to it okay stop right
do you guys have I'm the charge nurse or
do you guys have any questions for me
like how big is the baby it's full-time
something was crying well right now
she's being detained so she's not going
to leave from here at all period okay so
one of us will be in your custody right
yeah
yeah she's not under arrest but she is
detained okay she's not free to leave
that footage is just so tough to watch
this week we interviewed treviso's
attorney Gary Mitchell about why he
believes Treviso is not at fault in this
situation
not a single one of them told her that
she was pregnant
uh we need to examine you
and then when she wanted
to go to the restroom no nobody said
well wait a second
this is classic
uh this is a classic instance a female
needs to feel some need to go to the
restroom
maybe we better check and make sure
she's not delivering a baby for 48
minutes from the time they knew and had
the blood test back showing she was
pregnant they said at the nurses station
and in the doctor's office and did
nothing for this child so she is shocked
whenever she delivers a baby the nurses
and doctors failed her
the also the medical investigator has
failed her
hopefully her lawyers do not fail her
because that could be a catastrophic
result but once the facts all come out
I'm absolutely convinced that not only
will we be able to show that she's
totally innocent but we'll be able to
show
the uh
what some people might call malpractice
that took place
some strong words right there Terry if
Treviso was found not guilty of murder
what's the likelihood that you would be
convicted of tampering with evidence
well I think she actually could be found
not guilty of murder if those types of
arguments that we just heard were made
but even if she's guilty or not guilty I
think the tampering is the one piece of
the charge that will stick that means
that she actually altered or destroyed
or fabricated evidence to try to protect
herself or someone else but here to
protect herself when she delivered the
baby of course they're claiming she did
not know she was pregnant but once she
delivered that baby and she put it in
the trash can you have to ask yourself
she knew it was a baby and what was she
trying to cover there so I think if you
put this in front of a jury even if she
didn't understand before she went in
that restroom that she was pregnant once
she delivered the baby the attempt to
hide what had happened I think is going
to get her guilty and we've seen this
before and I think she will be guilty on
the charge for tampering with that
evidence well Brian this interview that
the attorney did did it help Treviso did
it help her defense in any way yeah
Jesse usually as a defense attorney I'm
not a big fan of defense attorneys going
up there and and giving out so much of
their defense but here I do think it
helps now in terms of the tampering with
evidence case I think as Terry said
she's probably dead in the water there
but Brooks Kyler Richardson only got
about three to four months of probation
for that charge so if they can get that
that's a win but let's focus on the
murder charge the attorneys say she went
to the hospital for lower back pains
said on a scale of one to ten she told
the hospital it was a 10. now I looked
this up one of the main signs of late
term miscarriages is get this pain and
cramping to the abdomen and lower back
so the question becomes is did she go to
the hospital exhibiting signs of early
onset miscarriage and then freak out
when the baby came out possible and if
it actually is true that she was not
told that she was pregnant before she
goes into the bathroom that's a game
changer for the defense and also this
body worn camera where she says the baby
didn't cry that's going to be a big
point of contention okay so it's going
to quite the battle between the
prosecution and the defense Brian Terry
thank you both so much thanks everybody
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we will see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
foreign